my dad doesn't I don't know he's got a
very small penis yeah I remember taking
shower you know even as a five bills
like why do I have a bigger dick than
you even though his father
Yanis Pappas is one of my best friends
we have our pockets history happiness
and we we bond over that like his dad is
a little has a little dick - it's like
something that we both know it's like
wow why do I dads have such small dicks
my dad's hung it's pretty cool
it's adorable
[Music]
and we're back it's you up with Nikki
Glaser full studio right now we got
Krista Stefano mm-hmm
what up I would get you foot inserts for
Valentine's Day I would get you that's
so no I would get you like a treatment
too like for your pronation cuz that's
you said you suffered from right not
anymore though okay just trying to say
it publicly and not a creepy way I just
would like to tell you haven't seen
anything till you see my really I would
never take out my foot I would rather
get felt like my feet right now are so
gross I should have gotten a pedicure
yesterday you would love to bring them
out but like when you put pot but that's
I know it's how you feel but like when
you mail them out on your Comedy Central
show for me you know what I think it is
because I think I think like their it
depends on like what like was forming in
your brain like as you know whatever sex
thing happened with my mom and my aunt's
feet are like hideously disgusting so
yeah I don't mind I keep saying that
well let me just enjoy the rest of the
room Andrew Colin is here don't forget
it boy and now we have Daniel schloss in
studio comedian daniel schloss I'm
excited to have you here I've watched
all your Conan's I'm well aware of you
from that you've two-hour special out
now on Netflix two separate hours in one
batch yeah on Netflix currently called
dark and jigsaw yeah so once called Dark
One's called jigsaw yeah what is what's
the difference between these two ones by
my dead sister and one's ended at
seventy five marriages hilarious ones
what one is about my dead sister and the
other one a has ended 75 mileages on
20,000 relationships wait wait what do
you mean I'm being cited into the show
is cause 20,000 breakups and I'm being
cited in 75 separate divorce papers well
okay can you I'm so that's such a
bug that's crazy
why can you give me a shorter yeah it's
my opinions on love and my opinions and
love her correct oh my god
let's get into it what are your opinions
on love I think we have romanticized the
idea of romance and I think it's
cancerous I think people are so
desperate to get into relationships that
they're willing to sail for just
something because we'd rather have
something than nothing and when you
raise in a world of Disney princesses
and princes you sit there you go if I'm
not in a relationship I'm a broken human
being and I hate people in relationships
that bracket by the relationships as if
they're more secure than I am in
themselves when they're not because you
never learned how to love yourself so
you employed someone else to do it for
you
yeah yeah first number one I feel
like you're Scottish me I'm not into
fate though no bucket oh I'm not have a
weird childhood foot 14 oh yeah everyone
wants their mother you agree on that
that's my theory is that when a guy
rejects you like my friends always go
you know like he said he didn't want to
be in a relationship but now he's dating
this girl and she's not even as cute as
me she's not as funny and I go yeah
because he's looking for his mom and
she's like but she's not funny you're
kidding I'm like neither is his mom his
mom is not funny or cute and he finally
found her don't you do you think there's
some truth to that sure I only like a
girl if she'll my dad I had a kid
like with a woman that I barely knew
like second third date in got pregnant
we had a child and before I had that I
was like the opposite of what of what
you just said I was like oh I want a
wife and I want this but now that I have
a child and I kind of understand what
like the real love towards her is I'm
with you where I'm like I don't I feel
like some of my some of my closest
friends like I knew one more my friend
is getting married I'm like you're just
doing this because you think you have to
do this because everybody in the
neighborhood's getting married I'm like
this isn't I wouldn't say this to her
but I was like this isn't going to work
in my head I was like it's you're just
trying to follow some trend right now
you don't really love this guy yeah but
again nah I just went and had fun at the
wedding and now they're divorced
because I'm like you see like I knew
that this was going to happen it's was
it real none of it was real you're just
you're just a follower
yeah we do the rest to emulate the rest
of society and whenever the rest of the
society is in a relationship you just
say they go and that's the pressure than
the rest the world puts on you because
they sit there nobody Telex about how
shet their relationship actually is yeah
because we live the Instagram generation
of me and this one going for coffee
climbing a goddamn Hill together
you're like oh my god Sarah loves John
and John's a dick so therefore it must
be worth it to stay in this relationship
with this terrible human being
and then you just end up banging someone
they make you and you're like
this all dude yeah this is me
forever
yeah because marriage it's kind of like
an archaic principle anyway I mean you
only used to know the people in your
village when marriage was a thing in
like you and marriage it was a business
decision so all of our grandfathers were
stalkers every one of our grandfathers
every story as always I saw your gran
didn't like me at first and you're like
gee she's not a horse I agree
man it is but they're okay I've always
been on like this marriage is an archaic
thing and I don't need it and you and
it's it's bound to fail you keep changed
too much to be with someone forever
right but then I do see marriages where
I'm like oh it looks like there are some
good ones you do I'm not against
relationship and I'm not against true
love why I am against is people getting
into relationships because they
feel they have to like I I do believe I
want to get married I want to have kids
like I know that for a fact but I'm not
gonna fart Jam the first person
that walks into my goddamn life into
that place and just like I'm not I'm not
going to force it to happen and I
believe that 90% of relationships are
people that force these things to happen
and that's why the divorce rate is so I
and I know it's true because my show
where I feel these opinion has caused
20,000 breakups I know I'm right
yeah I mean what um what do you think
the secret is to like a good marriage
though like love you have to love
yourself that is essential yeah because
otherwise you other if you don't love
yourself you're going to employ someone
else to do it for you
or you're gonna pick someone who doesn't
really love you either because if you
don't love yourself you can't love
someone who actually loves you because
you're gonna be like you have bad taste
yeah you don't you don't respect them so
it's just like how could you possibly
me
- love yours yeah you have to love
yourself and that's I think yeah that's
a good yeah I don't know I think
curiosity might I think when you were in
your toys shag everything yeah I
go I surely also is the number one cause
of divorce I reckon you said there
people get married too young and and
then yeah 20 or 30 and they go what
if I was single what if I was single
what I reckon I get so much or
dick and you wouldn't yeah but you don't
know that because you got married when
you were and I think it happens
naturally because 20s even like early
30s I was like that just whatever I'm
sorry I just want to get with girls I
won't have sex xx whatever but now I'm
34 now I'm just like I don't want to
keep hooking up with women cuz like I
don't want to get mono you know like I
just don't want to get sick depends
jigsaw though is the one that people
have cited in their divorce yeah
somebody comes to my show in in New York
next week and she's bringing our divorce
papers because I'm gonna get I want to
get photos because people genuinely
question these up and I'm like no no
this is all true I've had couples like
break up you know what couples bang
after my shows there's a lot of anal
that has been happening from my comedy
and like banging but I also think I make
people look at their significant other
and kind of go what's go what's
interface to razors there was a girl who
went to your show last how did you do
that I guess she did the seller last
night you did she
DM me at like 2:00 a.m. she's like just
saw Nikki show are you up so she what
yeah so she was just like you know it's
not my intention but like if you're
talking about sex and I'm telling guys
like what to do and so I think they want
to go home and like do it right yes yeah
it's like the life lesson they go huh
I'm going to go home and take this new
knowledge that I've gathered yeah
absolutely I don't care it's like I do
it but like people are learning stuff
and it sounds like people are learning
stuff from from this absolutely yeah and
also there's other things about there's
I talk about shaving your ass in my show
and I know a lot right yeah wait what
you're for it you're for absolute
nobody wants like a hairy asshole I just
don't think I've never done anything
with the ass I've never received any and
stuff or given any a stuff with a close
shave recently the Turkish barber so
yeah I would love to grow at the front
and have nothing in the back because the
back it doesn't even hurt to remove like
that part of getting your is the best
part you know when you go in and you get
a complete waxing Jen okay
the front part hurts so much it's the I
mean I've stopped doing it because it's
like I'm subjecting myself to the worst
pain imaginable and I get stressed
before and after and I hate it but the
best part is when she's like can you
bend over I'm like oh yeah let's get
back there that's not you don't even
feel it at that point for some reason
it's much more enjoyable and experienced
back there then how long does the
Brazilian last like I mean what are you
telling this forest ring you're doing
this pain for a week and I personally
like a bush personally I don't I don't
know I just don't I've never thought one
way it like once I'm in the mode
sexually I just don't care like it would
be preferable we were all had no hair
because hair is Gorelick it's not ideal
but like what's the point of pubic I
guess it's a keep intersection in say so
if you feel the bugs getting in the rest
of my deck then that makes no sense like
that my bell ends not here yeah
it looks a little cuter yeah you look
like you have a cute piece it's very
cute yeah exactly I would describe
it's adorable filling really I'm not a
grower nice average size good piece yeah
[Laughter]
it's just fine six seven maybe maybe six
well six like ten six and seven to be
very big different you know what my
cross to bear is so I have an overactive
Cowper's gland which like makes sperm so
like I get huge loads I've huge loads
but it takes a while to rejuvenate so
what doctor I'm Tony I'm the good I'm a
perfect guy if a woman wants to have
children because I have a lot of sperm
per load but if they're just looking to
have like rat like you like filling her
up like a cream pudding just
like I would I'm not the right guy
because I can't have like five sex once
I can't have sex now again for a few
days but if you're looking to have a
baby I can get you pregnant every shot
so wait you can well I can but it's it's
it take it's a lot I certainly can't
have sex twice in a day but I really
never could I came twice on a plane I
know maybe you can't have kids but
that's my cross to bear with you is that
you need you need a couple days buffer
before you're ready to like give it a
good load if you want a kid though I'm
your guy every couple days if you every
couple days I can we can try this
because it's so much sperm per load but
it takes a why would you do that for a
lesbian couple are you like like just
because I think that you would be a good
if you're offering no I donated mice I
donated sperm when I was seven cups 27
yeah but I signed papers to never know I
didn't want to know anything so I could
have a child possibly do
you've got thousands told I was told by
the people at the clinic
that you know it's up to me because I
stuff this no they tell you like what
where they think their sperm what they
you know how and they were saying
because get the ball yeah because of how
much absolutely there's a picture me and
level of education that was well yeah so
they were like this this is a prop most
likely will be on Maury soon absolutely
yeah but they can't they can't ever like
but y'all check me they have no wet womp
well you don't know when they see how
huge their loads are picture of
you and they see you on TV they go
that's the guy whose reach out yeah I
wouldn't mind but at the time yeah I
mean out I know it's like you know I'm
just doing this because you notice as a
kid when you like your girlfriend like
early on that you had an insane amount
of calm well I just compared to your
friends yeah yeah I just didn't know if
it is but after having like sexual
encounters buckin um do you have dude
like it was so much you know it's like
it and so I was like I don't know is
this so white and I was like uh I don't
know what I thought that this is what it
was no what if what have people been
learning from your special your special
just came out a couple weeks ago the
feedback you're getting what are people
taking from do you know what the
feedback actually has been which I'm
actually happy about is a lot of people
have been saying similar things like hey
I'm happy that you there's a comic like
nowadays is like taking a chance like
III in the sense of like saying words
you really shouldn't say like in my
special I say like my dad calls me a
homo for eating blueberry
yogurt and they're like I'm happy that
you said that like and gay people to
have been like yeah I'm happy that like
you're not censoring your words and
you're just saying what it is and we
like that you're being somewhat honest
so I think what do you mean someone well
no I mean so so that has been the
overwhelming and a lot of people have
been saying you know I feel like you're
just like having a conversation with me
which which I like because I don't like
you know I'm not the community who's
like oh here's my joke here's my joke
like I like it when people like oh you
know you were just being funny for an
hour as opposed to like here's my next
joke here's my next joke so that the
feedback that I wanted is what I've been
getting and so far nobody has on it
too hard then that means it's good yeah
yeah Noah watched it right loved it she
was like being yeah she really loved it
no it was my favorite modest right now
but you like enjoyed it yeah no it was
[Laughter]
the size of his loads you know
[Music]
you